in his inaugural address Biden set the
tone for all that would follow
a rise of political extremism white
supremacy domestic terrorism that we
must confront and we will defeat
very optimistic and his attorney general
and the FBI became maniacally focused on
advancing that narrative with
increasingly ominous warnings
racially motivated violent extremists as
a group are the most dangerous of the
domestic violence extremist groups and
within that the white supremacists are
the most dangerous and most least lethal
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race
specifically those who advocate for the
trans day of Vengeance gain steam days
after Audrey Hale a transgender
massacred six at a Christian School
Garland didn't see the need to issue any
warning about growing anti-christian
hate across the country
would he have been so reluctant if let's
say I don't know some conservative group
had planned a Patriots stand ready rally
and that was scheduled to happen just
days after some right-winger shot up a
school
of course not
and we certainly all know that CNN would
have put a microphone in the face of
every Congressman on Capitol Hill asking
questions like do you think the
so-called Patriots event should go
forward as parents are grieving
but here reporters tried to turn the
table on Republicans
confronting one local congressman who
posed with firearms for a family holiday
card
any regrets about that Facebook post and
the photo
um from your Christmas card why would I
regret a photograph with my family
exercising my rights to bear arms
now thankfully the trans day of
Vengeance was canceled by the event
organizers but true to form they didn't
cancel it out of respect for those
murdered but rather because they say
they were facing threats
now remember the Democrats narrative
will always be that conservative
Christians are the biggest threat facing
America at any given time
thus no matter what unfolds even a trans
person murdering Christians at a
Christian School
the left's focus will be how anti-trans
hate will spread in the aftermath
and when republican-led State
legislatures Advance bills to ban things
like genital mutilation and hormone
shots for children under 18. the left
says it's just more evidence of that
pernicious anti-trans hate
The Washington Post proves our point in
this headline
Nashville's shooting exploited by right
to escalate anti-trans rhetoric are you
with me here people
now the response from the White House
was equally as shameful yet entirely
predictable
our hearts go out to those the trans
Community as they are under attack right
now
they're under attack
and Joe Biden chimed in saying
transgender Americans shape our nation's
soul
but a wave of discriminatory state laws
is targeting transgender youth
terrifying families and hurting kids
tone deaf and false
the president his administration and all
the radical gender activists they're all
lying they all know that this isn't
about hating anyone this is about
protecting children from political
sexual and medical exploitation
and for Biden a practicing Catholic to
cheer this on is reprehensible
equally so is his vilification of those
who disagree with him whipping The
pro-trans Fringe into an absolute Frenzy
now just a few days ago trans activists
tried to storm the Kentucky State
Capitol building after the legislature
there voted to override a veto by their
Democrat Governor of a bill to ban sex
surgeries and hormones for minors
shame
[Applause]
[Music]
well you can call it a transerection I
guess one protester you saw there even
played the part of their equivalent of
the Q Anon shaman
and similar chaos yesterday in Tennessee
where hundreds protested at the Capitol
there calling for a gun ban and berating
the republican-led legislature they even
made their way onto the state capitol
floor
no peace
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
and go what they said about the parents
who showed up at school board meetings
and look at what happened in these two
states of course no threat to democracy
here the media just framed it as another
kind of run-of-the-mill protest even a
family affair
hundreds of people showed up today I
mean probably about 1500 maybe even
upwards of that showing out a lot of
young people a lot of young students
skipping school a lot of parents
bringing their young kids here as well
oh
Halid right uh wrong
[Applause]
my taxes paid for this building we can
stand wherever we want we're not
touching you listen you're not trying to
protect them you're trying to protect
the powers
that argument about our tax dollars let
us go anywhere we want in the capital
that didn't work for the January 6
protesters well you can see though how
this could spiral quickly out of control
Democrats are getting up a divisive
hateful dynamic in America now folks
have every right to protest I'll always
support that right but this is something
very different the White House is
lighting a powder keg here playing a
cynical game of division and distraction
we don't yet know what the Nashville
Killers motive was but Democrats toxic
disparaging rhetoric against those who
disagree with them must stop before
another tragedy happens hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else